today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
gray block pizza get that
get her today's episode is brought to
you by a skills share skill shares an
online learning platform look let's be
honest dude a lot of us are idiots right
a lot of us all know [ __ ] right
well skills share is a place where you
can change all that it's an online
learning platform with over 20,000
classes in business design technology
and more everything from Facebook ads
for e-commerce how to make Android apps
and and how to produce music whether
you're trying whether you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set start
a Sode hustle or just explore a new
passion skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving trust me instead
of going to school college something
long do Skillshare nail and you as a tpw
listener can get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right Skillshare offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access for over twenty
thousand classes for just 99 cents go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo again go to
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo to start
you two months now also next week we'll
have a Halloween episode and you can
send pictures of your costumes so I can
I guess I'll roast them maybe or just I
don't know look at them just whatever
you can email them to producer at Theo
von comm and that's for next week's
episode pictures of your Halloween
costumes what's up you little flannel
wearin spunk ponies how are you huh
you arguably adorable little muff and
monstrous you ready
it's October we did it it's late October
we made it this far how does that feel
how does that feel
[Music]
enjoy it
celebrate man
[Music]
that is celebrate by Spencer Jacob growl
and that is our intro music happy
October and I'm I am I'm here you're
here this is how it works out this is
how it works out made it in today back
here into the studio exhausted I mean I
feel like my skin just wants to just
just crawl off of my body and just go
hide and just a you know in a in a
bedside table or in a little secret you
know drawer or secret trapdoor I mean my
skin is just like are you really gonna
carry me around and do something else
with me because I can't handle I can't
handle this we I just got back from
Appleton you know we just got back from
Appleton I say we sometimes you know I
don't like to feel alone so saying we
kind of puts me in a in a groupthink
space in my head
Appleton Wisconsin in Wisconsin that's
you know that's dairy that's the dairy
belt you know you you you'll step on you
you'll you'll step in something outside
you might go what is that and it's just
nothing that's a little bit of 2% you'll
see some stray yogurt just you know a
chunk of yogurt just kind of roll them
down a hillside you it's it's it's kind
of baffling you you know you'll be
talking to somebody and suddenly just
you know some skim milk will just fall
right out their mouth or a cheese curdle
just you know a magician will walk up
and just you know pull a cheese curd out
from behind your ear and that's
Wisconsin that's up there and that's
those dairy the thus the the dairy
people and they love dairy up there and
they love to just I mean like you and I
we probably would look at a cow and just
think oh that's an animal but those
people up there they look at a cow and
they'd be like Oh
look at this [ __ ] right here
this little milk jug with hoofs we had
uh so all sold out shows all sold out
shows in Appleton Wisconsin and thanks
thanks thanks for for the joining people
you know a bunch of different people
come out fast Steve came out I think his
name was fat Steve or fat Chris I can't
remember but this gentleman this
gentleman sent me a UH a DM and he goes
hey man just letting you know I'm coming
through Saturday night and I'm gonna be
the fattest [ __ ] dude you'll see a
whole weekend and I want to give a
checkmate to that man because he he
honored his word I mean this guy did I
patted him on the back and and then I
had to tell him I patted him on the back
because he couldn't feel it I mean this
dude was huge and beautiful and he wore
a big kind of bright bright green
you know safety green you know the funny
thing is when people get and I'm not
saying this to shame this gentleman at
all he was in a good mood about it and
so and so we can laugh with him and he
said look I'm gonna be you know imma be
a fan is felling that you know I'm gonna
be the fattest the fattest sugar hole in
the enamel you know I'm gonna be the
fattest cavity and he was and he came
out with his daddy and his daddy looked
you know like somebody from you know the
Hobbit a little bit kind of a handsome
sort of older gentleman but you know a
very Midwestern just a smile on his face
he had a built-in smile you know like
somebody was just kind of like you know
like the Lord was just kind of tickling
him under his chin
and they came out and they enjoyed
themselves in that big fella he was
wearing a bright green because if you
notice sometime when people get real
large a lot of the colors that they can
wear our safety colors bright orange you
know you'll see some black people
they'll be real large and they'll wear
bright orange you know or you know Shawn
dresses she'll have bright bright green
and you're like dang what size is that
and this this fella wasn't no different
he came out and he had he had to he had
that safety green kind of like emergency
kind of green you know if you you know
if there was like police at night by the
side of the road and they have flares
and stuff and something bad happen and
then also they're wearing green vests he
had that color green because when you
get past three XL and stuff like that
all the colors they put on your safety
because I think you know it's uh here's
you're probably a little bit of a of a
health risk I think it's certain you
know it's certain poundage --is but it
was good that he came out man you know
it was good that he came out because
everybody enjoyed it
man I and it was a it started to get
chilly it snowed it snowed one day so
that was really awesome
but fat Pete came out little Nolan they
had these dudes that like this kind of
like I don't know fraternity dudes a
spit in each other's mouths is that like
point-blank range
so they said it was like a you know a
trick that they did but I didn't see the
real it didn't see much you know like
too much trickery to me it just seemed
like a couple dudes just spitting in
each other's mouths you know it seemed
like something you know a bit of a dark
art you'd find him one of the in the
crevices of the internet but yeah a
little nolan came out
vixie does gal Vic's he came through who
else that lady they kept crying
there was a lady they kept crying for no
for no reason after the show and she had
I think she'd been you know drinking and
eating at the same time which is popular
and I you know when I used to really you
know ingest booze I would do it and she
was drying her tears with a
with a hamburger bun and there's
something honestly sexy about that when
you see a lady's emotions just flowing
out of her face and she just dabbing
them [ __ ] up with uh with the top
half of a crescent roll yeah ma'am
erection erection town that's where I'm
headed
who else Oh some twins I met some dudes
there were twins uh and I'll say this
you know I'm talking about twins before
if you're twins
[ __ ] fight it out you know so many
times you see twins they're both living
they're both just kind of carrying on
with their existences or existence I I'm
not sure what the term is but [ __ ]
fight it out if your twins
fight it out B you know obviously God
wants y'all to compete and especially
this time of year [ __ ] figure it out
you know two people enter one person
leaves turn the holidays into a real you
know into a real fiesta I just think
that a lot of times twins these days
back in the old days if you saw twins
you'd see them fist fighting you know I
remember you drive down the street and
they'd see a couple twins over there
[ __ ] if he saw triplets they'd have
swords out in the yard because people it
was more about you know survival of the
fittest there's no way three of us are
gonna just meander around town just each
of us you know taking a 8 hours a you
know an eight-hour shift of at the same
life each day no you got to just you got
to have your own life so it's time to
cut corners so I'm just saying if you're
twins figure it out
figure it out you know I wonder
sometimes I was in the bathroom I
noticed I was in the bathroom at the
airport and I noticed that I noticed
that I get a little this is kind of how
territorial I get you know I'm not a
real bad boy you know I'm not that real
baby cat
and but I was in the bathroom I was at
the urinal and some dude was in the
toilet stall you know he was in one of
those you know little Doody closets you
know and I'm sure they have him in the
women's bathroom I never been in there
but but I've been in the men's bathroom
probably six or seven thousand times and
they had these little duty closets in
there they have urinal urinal by the
wall they have individual urinals you
can go up and pee all by yourself
and I you know I'm that I don't like
dudes coming up behind me so I pull a
lot of dudes don't do this I'll put my
I'll drop my pants right below my butt
so if you see me at the urinal you're
gonna see my ass you know and I've done
that since I was a child and that's the
way I learned to do it when I was young
young you put your pants all the way to
your ankles and stand there and pee but
you know then you know a lot of people
got to pervert and uh you know inverting
on each other and so people now they
only pull just their wiener out but not
me man I kind of meet in the middle and
I'll still pull the bump here it's just
below my ass when I pee at the urinal
but if you don't want to urinate and you
want to do something stronger out of
your back area then you can go into the
intimately in in one of these little
Duty closets you know special areas and
they got a lock on them you know because
people don't like to be bothered while
they trying to you know be shittin so
anyway anyway I'm in the urinal I'm at
the urinal and I'm just doing number one
out the front and some dude cleared his
throat in the in the you know in the
little wha cage in the duty cage and and
it was kind of you know this is a little
gross I guess but and I ended I just
farted you know I farted I just pushed
loud air out of my butt like my butt was
a horn and and I noticed that I did it
like in retaliation like this dude like
cleared his throat you know like and
then
I'd like to show territorial I like mom
you know I was like oh you think you
gonna you want to make you gonna clear
you throw it around here well I'm gonna
frickin you know I'm a sound that but
alarm and I'm gonna set the mood and so
I guess I just realized like and it was
involuntary by me it was like a
territorial type of thing so when it
comes to territory you know in the old
days a man when you fight your teeth in
your territory off you protect your
ground at all costs and that sort of
thing but we're not really having to do
that right now in the history of the
world and so so now what you're doing
what I would apparently why Matt as far
as territoriality is if I hear somebody
clear their throat you know then I will
you know do body gas in order to kind of
set the tone so but that that that's
what happened I was in appleton people
were nice it was you know I saw snowfall
they had a breakfast place I went to eat
breakfast and the breakfast place was in
a the breakfast place was in a it used
to be a funeral parlor and now they got
they got their mom list and now they
have omelets and they have you know they
got all kind of thing one having
breakfast omelets saw blueberries French
french toast and you know pancakes and
all of that and I was enjoying it just
living it up and uh and and it's just
wild to eat breakfast in a place where
the deceased where they used to have
funerals so that was one pretty cool
thing that was in Appleton that's it I
saw the leaves changing color you know
mother nature just doing her last you
know putting on her walk you know some
last little fancy evening gowns before
the before winter sets in and I'm trying
to think of what else I got into that's
it
I'm just grateful at her but he came out
somebody brought me a quartz rock a
magical pink quartz rock
and they said it have special powers in
it so I'm gonna hold that keep that on
the shelf here what else somebody
brought me over this piece of wood that
they chiseled something in it
you know a little bit of wood chiseling
and and that's it man
that's it Halloween's coming up I'm one
of Phoenix this weekend I'll be in
Phoenix Friday and Saturday night at the
Orpheum so I'm really I'm stoked about
that
then I'm going down to imma go have the
holidays with my nieces and nephews for
Halloween you know and get to see them
going down to New Orleans in Baton Rouge
speaking of Louisiana we have a duh
Dustin Poirier will be in the studio who
he will be on this on the guests episode
this week and he is a he is the number
three fighter I believe UFC and and he's
from Louisiana and really a unique
character and an honorable young man and
I'm excited to have somebody from my
home state who is doing something much
braver than me man that guys out there I
mean he's brave to be a real fighter you
know he can fight with his body you know
and I'm Andy I'm out here fighting you
know I'm out here going to self-help
therapy and all of that so but we're all
doing our own stuff and so I'm honored
to have him in this week he'll be coming
in but y'all be in Phoenix and I'll be
in Buffalo the week after if you have
friends in Buffalo send them out you
know tell him to come on out and get a
little bit of daddy's hitter I was
thinking man the spirits are all all the
spirits are gonna be coming back because
of Halloween and that's pretty cool you
know cuz you know it's wild to think
that when you when your body leaves here
when you die your spirit is just kind of
just milling around kind of like a like
the smoke coming off of a cigarette you
know your spirit is just like it's like
the universe you know it's like the you
it's just you know your spirit is
this warm kind of full-body kind of gas
that's inside of you and whenever you
die it seeps out of you it comes out it
kind of peels off your skin you know
because it's real real tight our spirit
is real real tight inside of us and
Halloween is that special time when all
the spirits get invited to the school
dance and they all everybody comes out
all the spirits and you'll see spirits
over in the distance you know a couple
of spirits out back behind the gym
smoking a giant you'll see you know you
might have a spirit uh you know touching
some ah you know trying to you know undo
another spirits brassiere and trying to
grab on to them those spur eddies you
feel me you have all you know you just
have spirits being spirit II and this
that time of year and so I was thinking
about people that I lost that you know
they had a buddy of mine little Freddie
and little Freddie he was a manager at
uh um he did you know management
Supermarket management an assistant
management and he he passed away this
year you know and he had he was a buddy
of mine down in Baton Rouge and he had a
little mustache and one thing I'll tell
you about um little Freddy man he loved
that mustache it was like a dachshund it
was just like a dachshund just living
just that was constantly just just
sleeping right on this right above his
lip and he loved that mustache man and
dude I would catch him but he'd to kind
of do this dude
a lot of men now do not know how to
treat their mustaches you know you'll
see a guy eating yogurt with like kind
of a sharp spoon right just right up and
putting it right up by his mustache or
you'll see somebody you know maybe
they're doing arts and crafts and
cutting doing some clipping or something
or you know uh doing some scrapbooking
with the scissors right by their
mustache and they'll cut some mustache
hair while they're do trying to make a
little worn them in or something and he
but just just men that don't know how to
treat
you know that front body that front body
little that third eyebrow
you know the mustache and and Freddie
this this man Freddie he treated his
mustache well did he used to do this
thing where he would put he would put
like neosporin he'd get like a quarter
tuba neosporin as put it all on it I
mean just look like he had just given a
[ __ ] to a damn banshee or something
you know look like he's just given a
[ __ ] to somebody that worked at UM at
a slumber J or something or you know one
of those big oil companies petroleum
because he just he'd have a whole just
quarter to of neosporin this lodged up
in that mustache and let that thang soak
up at night and and then in the morning
he'd clean it off oh my god that thing
just [ __ ] listen boy it would be hard
pressed right up against his face and
real slick looking you'd see him in the
front yard with a hose washing his
mustache and people don't do that people
don't do that at all but he passed away
so I'm sure his spirit will be out and
about soon and that's what I'm starting
to wonder I'm wondering like you know
like what spirits are on deck to come
back this Halloween when the Gateway
opens you know when the devil's his arms
out real wide I wonder who's gonna come
just
sneakin into our world it was good to be
in the Midwest I'll say that it was all
you know it's nice to be there and I can
just call a woman sweetheart or lady or
Love Bug or something like that if I
want to without getting looked at all
cross-eyed like you do here in Los
Angeles in Los Angeles you call the
girls sweetheart there's girl there's
women out here that they instead of
wanting to be in love they've decided
they just want to be mean
they just want to be mean and I'm not
saying it's all women but it's become
like a fad out here it's become like and
you see a lot of young people I see it
you know a lot of these young girls I
feel I get led into that you know you
know you you know that it's like I can't
even explain it but it's like they just
are wait all they're doing it they the
only reason they even want to spend time
around a man or even listen to a man is
just to call them out whenever he says
something just gets ridiculous so it's
nice to be in a regular place in America
where you could where I can say oh thank
you sweetheart in someone and and a
woman isn't gonna berate me because when
I listen for when I talk to people you
know I listen for the the the sound of
what's in their heart and I and I hope
that they would do the same for me and
usually people know you know if
somebody's being mean somebody's being
nasty or somebody's trying to pull the
just light the deepest whisker that's
just tied in here you know just tied
deep deep Indian nuts into that nudie
nudie bag people know and I just try to
be nice and it's nice to be and it was
nice to be in a place where you could
just be friendly with somebody without
having to get the the the exact without
saying young lady or ma'am or and just
getting looked at like you're a piece of
[ __ ]
just because somebody's so lonely that
they have nothing better to do than look
at you that way and that's just where
you see a lot of out here I feel like in
Los Angeles you know in LA it's a lot of
people whose dreams aren't coming true
and so they get upset and so they figure
well if I can't be you know if I can't
be without be happy then nobody else is
gonna a lot of that out here but i but
it was nice to be in a place where
that's not what's going on you know but
a lot of great people came out in
Appleton
and it just felt good man man we had a
great I don't know if you listen to that
Maurice Clarett episode but that was
awesome it was nice to be you know
that's one thing about this podcast has
been neat has been just the just being
inspired around people you know we got
to have a conversation and here Maurice
was in here and uh and it was great when
we had a conversation about race we had
a conversation about you know you heard
a lot about learning you know just
hitting lows but coming back from them
and finding your own power man it just
brought a tear to my eye just listening
to that guy he is his story I mean it's
just so powerful it's so powerful I
think Murray should go into politics I
you know I don't know if I met a man
really that I know who has such an
uncanny ability to articulate his
emotions but with and to listen and
interact without judgment you know he
really stays away from judgment and that
allows him to see what's going on so
much better you know and we got to talk
it was just fun man we talked about
different stuff you know I mean I
thought the conversation I was kind of
surprised at God in the race but you
know you never know when that's gonna
happen and that's okay but hopefully
we'll have have him back and have you
know those guys from business and biceps
back again in the future
what else man I'm so I'm so tired man
I'm sorry if uh you know I want to be
more funny sometimes I just can't even
think that much you know my brain
sometimes feels like have you ever seen
one of those gumball machines
and and like nobody uses it forever and
it's just the gum is just sitting there
sometimes that's when my brain feels
like just like that machine just dude
and sometimes you know what remember
when that rumor came out there were
roaches and gumball machines and people
lost their [ __ ] minds it was right
around the same time that the rumors
came out that there was a snake in all
the ball pits at the McDonald's and
Burger King's and that's when they
started getting rid of a lot of them and
they're taking the fun out of the world
remember that it was some fake story
like oh yeah big Rhonda was eating a
double-double Anna Anna um Anna um king
snake better yes she got bit by a king
snake at the Burger King you're like
what this is sound fishy
oh she was having a fillet of fish at
the Burger King and got bit by a king
right remember that [ __ ] though dude
people were [ __ ] losing their mind
being and everybody lawsuits out the
yang people were getting bit by snakes
at their house and then saying they were
at the McDonnells trying to get that
money a lot of [ __ ] people out there
cutting corners man cutting corners
let's take a couple calls that came in
man from the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three you can
always hit the hotline and I want to
also let any men out there know that
live in the Los Angeles area if there's
some experience that you are having
trouble with if you are struggling with
something and and would like to be
possibly involved in you know in in
figuring it out in real time on this
past weekend and doing something in
person maybe hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and let us know about your struggle let
us know what's going on it can be can be
anything anything
going on in your life if you're feeling
you know anything has got you down
something that's Arthas got you off or
something that's got you confused or
uncertain anything out there if you're
living in the Los Angeles area and it's
men or women and that's for both gender
Jin died actually what else I will be as
I told you this weekend in Phoenix then
I'll be in Buffalo Salt Lake City
Washington DC Addison Texas and
Lexington Kentucky the only ones that
are not sold out are Buffalo and
Lexington so man it's crazy people are
coming out to the shows what an exciting
time you know what an exciting time is
crazy to think how long I've been
working at this job and then be finally
catching a little bit of breakage and
you know I mean like the Lord is just
just busting a nut and it's just laying
it all on right here on your boy you
know praise God brother praise God okay
let's hit a couple calls here we go hey
this is Daniel from South Carolina I
just was calling to give some advice for
the goddess and rotc oh yeah thank you
for calling Daniel last week at the end
of the episode we had a caller who
called saying he was considering he'd
been in ROTC at school you know at high
school or whatever and y'all know that
[ __ ] is just children running around you
know throwing fake grenades at each
other and eat you know eating MREs
behind the gymnasium this [ __ ] and
playing with wooden guns and all of that
no disrespect but you know [ __ ] that's
what that [ __ ] is you know people giving
each other buzz cuts and low-key
closeted homosexuality but the young man
that called in and we'll go back to his
call in just a second so I'll play his
call for you from last week he was
uncertain about whether or not he should
actually go in the military to appease
his family he was unsure about what he
wanted to do you can listen to a piece
of that right here
what's up Theo my name is Jesse I'm an
Air Force ROTC cadet in college and I'm
trying to figure out this whole life
thing having a hard time pretty much
balancing everything in turn
figure out if this is going in the
military is exactly what I want to do
and now let's get back to this
gentleman's response and suggestion for
him homework I'm just going to say that
I was in a similar position I was at
Clemson University I decided to go to
the National Guard route but I actually
decided not a good officer and I went
enlisted and to be quite honest with you
I regretted it you know just like Bo
says if you have the opportunity you
know go for it because that's one of
those things that's going to be with you
for the rest of your life and it's you
know you serve honorably your country
you know America is a great place
regardless of what people say you know
and and I agree with that 100% America
is a great place regardless of what
people say and it's a shame that a lot
of people have big platforms and they
choose and live in America and make
great money off of it and choose to
speak so ill of it and that kind of
stuff breaks my heart man
but but but let's finish this call
that's coming in here he's saying you
know if you can go and get it done and
you are heavily considering it then
maybe it's worth it you know you will
have that time and it is extremely I do
think it's honorable you know of course
I didn't do it
so if I could obviously that's easy for
me to say but I you know there's
something inside of a man or this man
anyway that will always feel a little
less than for not having served this
country let's hear more if not a lot of
people even have the opportunity to you
know to serve their country and in a few
and especially as an officer it's going
to stay with you it's going to be a
positive thing for your whole life you
know they'll tell you you know embrace
the suck you know I'm going to hear that
a lot but like video said you know it's
not going to last forever at all in the
last couple years you know and then you
can just get out to be in the airports
to I mean you got a made man you got all
benefits and you're in the Air Force so
you're going to smarter guys so I would
say do it but again if you're going to
do it go all the way but if you're not
going to do it you know don't feel bad
know like Bo said
again just be happy with your choice and
make a choice I think is the best thing
and and Jessie yeah I just want to let
you know that we are going to send you
we had about 30 or 40 responses all from
veterans and I want to thank thank the
men and women who have served thank you
very much you know my job is freedom of
speech this right here is because it's
directly because of you guys so even
though you're listening to me
I'm doing this be I'm only capable of
doing this because of you and I
appreciate you and thank you but yeah we
get we're gonna send you all of those
responses Jesse all 30 or 40 of those
that came in so you will have a vast
array of suggestions from different
military members and people who have
been in and out of ROTC that you can
listen to so but yeah I think you know
whatever you choose just try in and make
a choice that way you're not just living
in that gray area because living in the
gray can be kind of [ __ ] me I can feel
it you know kind of a aurash if you will
man you get a ward up where the motel
you all right man let's let's take one
more response I came in for ROTC Jesse
II know what LP over the years I love
the podcast you make me laugh while I'm
trying to [ __ ] like pipette and do lab
work other stuff and also cause you do
well I hope man you know one of my game
what am i sometimes in my dark art brain
I will lay there and think at night that
somebody's trying to do some real
intricate flooring in there and I make
them laugh and they [ __ ] it up so so
then then I picture somebody walking
through their kitchen the next day and
one of the tiles is just a little bit
off and they're thinking man whoever did
the flooring in this place is [ __ ]
sucked
but they didn't suck man they [ __ ]
floored with joy in their heart and
that's that little laughter offset
that's why that little hitter is a
little bit offset because we hit them
with that giggle giggle ok onward take
more Hey
want to leave a comment for the young
man out there trying to get it other my
ROTC and not sure about the decisions
he's making and all this all this stuff
that's coming from a place of fear of
the unknown and that's natural but just
realize young man well first of all my
Navy Marine Corps veteran and thank you
for service sir
and we're working on a piece right now
and you hear that Jesse right there he's
working his PhD now that's s commitment
you know that's you get that Drive
that's the thing that I've always been
jealous of my friends have went into the
military early is that they are up and
at them every day achieving their goals
for the rest of their life onward marine
biology and it would not have been
possible without the choices that I made
way back when to join the military and
the disappointment I got while I was in
there you know just all those
experiences but just use your heart and
your nuts fish your guys and you know
what you want to do before you ever ask
for advice but you can't go wrong with
the military just make sure you read the
contract pick the right jobs medical
jobs are cool and yes good luck although
you don't need it that's like I said you
can't lose [ __ ] there you go you can't
lose he said if you're already being
aware and thinking about your choices
man then I think you're you're already
halfway there but best of luck to you
Jesse and we'll see you all of them and
you're gonna get all of them hitters you
know all those response hitters and
suggestions from different listeners oh
we have some good calls that came in let
me do tonight my eyes are heavy that's
where I'm at so I'm a cruise through a
few of these and get some rest I'm gonna
take care of myself better this week you
know I had a little bit of juice earlier
and I jus stuck a couple of carrots in
dude I never look huh I don't you know I
ain't in all that serial-killer type
[ __ ] or nothing like that right I mean I
watched some Dateline and stuff like
that but I don't know if you ever used a
juicer or not but dude you start to
think [ __ ] maybe I could be a murderer
bruh
you take a whole carrot and just
it's just spanning and just juice and
everywhere and you can hear it just hear
the carrot just screaming just then you
cut up an apple and just put the slices
down there just and then you cut up a
grapefruit and get all them little juicy
little them little savoir-faire them
little slices and you just you just
dangle it over the little a juicer just
spinning just just just slashing a
little juicer thing and that you can
hear the little grapefruit sliver just
being like and then you just drop it in
there and you do that with all of his
buddies to the whole [ __ ] grapefruity
family the next thing you know man you
sipping on that cup of juicy juicy
hitter you're like dang I don't I
thought I want to just juice but I might
I might want to be involved in the dark
arts and that's what I've been noticing
about myself when I start juicing let's
take another call that came into the
hotline here we go I feel it's visa from
Spokane there was a an onion caller
called regarding being afraid of
commitment and you said you're afraid of
being locked into another reality not
wanting to be locked in your other truth
but yeah that was last week I was
talking about commitment and how yeah I
feel like if I commit to something or
one of the my feet one of my fears of
the reason why I struggle sometimes with
commitment is because if I commit to
something then like my story ends you
know and I'm locked into like a reality
you know locked in or like a way of life
and
I never wear as a child I didn't feel
comfortable being locked into a way of
life
Oum word have you considered that you
know having deep experiences with
someone else whether it's a friend or
girlfriend can be a woman at least give
me that credit oh man some of your
richest memories you know because when I
look back on everything as near and dear
to me is what you know I experience and
share with someone else that is really
the best memories to me yeah I respect
that man you know yeah yeah it's
interesting it's almost like something
didn't even really happen
it didn't happen with someone else
you know if something happened just to
you
it's almost sad you know it's almost
the world only really you only really
get points in your heart for things that
happen involving someone else you know
homework after my happiness is depended
on another you know it never is that
comes within from within but it's still
those bonds that make life so fulfilling
I won't love for you as I have for me as
long as you have self-love I don't think
you can lose yourself to someone else it
only adds to your story and it doesn't
lock you down I hope that you find that
I love you bro
gang burr gang man I appreciate that you
know I think I still have a lot to like
kind of you know figure out and work on
in some of that world you know cuz it's
funny cuz recently I've been thinking
man maybe I'll you know just kind of you
know maybe I'll just be you know kind of
a loner in that regard for the rest of
my life you know and not like in a sad
way I'm not trying to be melancholy or
melancholy whichever one it is but just
that you know at a certain point it's
like you just get it's like I don't want
to I get tired of dealing with that type
of you know the bother to create
connections that I've really struggled
to have sometimes and so sometimes it's
like you know maybe that's not the best
use of my time is to spend it trying to
figure all of that out sometimes and
maybe just you know focus on you know
trying to help others and not and you
know maybe not even think you know not
worry about my own stuff as much if I
find more progress then maybe I would
feel differently but
but yeah man look I appreciate your well
wishes dude and I appreciate you
thinking about that kind of stuff with
me you know uh I think I'm a late
bloomer you know and I'm kind of still
you know I'm just kind of still learning
I got that tadpole you know I got that
tadpole in me so I got that baby heart
you know I got that baby heart all right
let's take let's hit this other call
that came in homework baby is awesome oh
I'm from Owensboro Kentucky what's up
Austin I'll be in Lexington Kentucky in
December thank you for calling Austin
from Owensboro more and I've listened to
your show and heard yet heard how you
were struggling with cigarettes man and
oh yeah boy them little you know them a
little knick Adickes breath you know
next thing you know you're sucking on
one of them little baby white [ __ ]
lamb legs out in the front yard and do
when I smoke a cigarette astara yeah
I'll be yelling it I'll start yelling at
children and [ __ ] I don't even have
children I'm like you [ __ ] you
know get off you know y'all using my
damn ship arroba as a bike ramp you know
I'll get pissed dude I'll get keyed up
but I'll roll my pants up dude I used to
roll my pants up all the way up to my
[ __ ] rabbi my nuts man when I first
started smoking you know just to feel
that [ __ ] full body pulse when that
nicotine hit my arteries bruh
that [ __ ] would fire down my legs dude
and you could just feel that blood just
that nicotine just running up and down
those [ __ ] you know them long
naughty-naughty white stocks you know
them [ __ ] boo radley goal posts that
I called legs and then pale [ __ ]
aficionado
you know them then just impale parallel
bars that I called legs and that
nicotine would just just just race down
each one of them you know like tony
stewart driving an electrical current
and I'd roll my pant legs all the way up
you know just to feel that full [ __ ]
body fervor of that nicotine just God
you can feel it just ride right back up
your ass when it came up let's hear more
I don't have any advice per se but I
just want to say like I'm right there
with you because like I don't know what
to do man because I feel like I have to
change who I am as a person when I quit
smoking cigarettes and like I just don't
know if I'm ready for that yet but I
want to quit because they made me feel
terrible man I feel you dude they do
that's the truth they make me feel
terrible like I don't even enjoy a
cigarette if I smoke it I enjoy the
first hit of that thing and the other 17
hits
I don't enjoy they make me feel terrible
man
homeward but you know how it is in like
a small town man everybody smoked
cigarettes and drinks and [ __ ] and
smokes weed and so oh yeah that's also
how it is in everything politics
big business everything that's one thing
I start to realize there we kind of like
people look at small towns and say what
can you believe they look at all this
[ __ ] they're doing everybody's doing the
same [ __ ] but I feel you man I will say
this when you're in like more areas that
are you know don't have as much access
then yeah like you're not gonna be doing
as much cocaine maybe as you would be in
New York City whereas in Owensboro or a
smaller town you know you might be just
you know having cigarettes and liquor
more I really know what to do so I was
wondering if you had any concern or
comments or tips on how to not feel that
way like smoking as part of my lifestyle
you know I think there is something
there like you know part of it is it's
nice to go relax you know it's nice to
sometime sit out and have a cigarette
and get you that puffy you know and play
Magic Dragon with yourself out in the
front yard you know and looking
get the neighbor's wife and do that kind
of [ __ ] and you know you know maybe pull
your zipper down and flash that cack
meat real fast or something
and be wild but the problem for me is
when I get addicted when I'm then but
then I so then it's like I'm not just
enjoying one cigarette then next thing
you know I've enjoyed two cigarettes and
the third cigarette I'm not enjoying and
the second one I didn't really enjoy in
the second half of the first one I
didn't really enjoy so that's when it
gets tricky is when it starts to become
an addiction because the first half of
the first one yeah that's me it's kind
of my idea is maybe it's part of an
identity in the evening it's a
relaxation as part of a ritual but then
the the subsequent ones that's not even
me making that choice the one thing that
I do find for me that helps me get away
from even doing that at all is if I
meditate if I meditate then it then I'm
not making just I'm not reacting and
getting a cigarette I am instead
choosing of my brain take it just gives
my brain a little more peace so my brain
can be like oh I don't want a cigarette
instead of my brain just thinking
cigarette get cigarette my brain will
think cigarette and then I separate from
my brain will be like man I'm okay
meditation gives me that space it gives
me the space between my brain and myself
so I can make choices all right let's
take another call that came in homework
what up do it is Austin from Brentwood
what's up Austin from Brentwood and that
can be brewing with Tennessee or
Brentwood California let's hear more
okay send someone either we got them
sweet white court hitters up here baby
okay you want them corn hitters home
word I'm just calling it about my past
weekend on Sunday actually went out to
Lodi with my girlfriend at the time we
went skydiving boy okay you and the lady
went skydiving and that's really
skydiving used to be the original going
on a cruise like if you wanted to kill
your spouse you'd go on a skydive with
them and unhook them and now people do
that on cruises you know you get your
girlfriend a fancy drink with a you know
a cut-up
Apple hanging off the lip and you know
you tell her to back up a little more
back up a little more why are you taking
a picture of her and then you know you
throw a little bit of cinnamon in her
eyes or something push her off the
balcony but skydiving was the original
back up back up cinema and I balcony
trick that that a lot of men are doing
on cruises now let's hear more it was
out of this world we landed and eight
years of being in a relationship with my
girlfriend I uh after the marry me and
she said yes baby
whoo gang gang boy so you literally took
that leap wow that's the best weekend
right there and this is a submission for
our best weekend more pretty penny on
that ring but it was all worth it my
diving now I got a fiance man I don't
know how much you did much better than
that
thank you man Gang Gang bruh you got
that fine-ass dude you got you getting
French brewing you getting fun wine when
you get French man that's when you get
that Phi Anse and you sky dog both y'all
landed and that's the good thing about
skydiving is this is why you go
skydiving before you get engaged because
then you see if the Lord really wants
you all to both be together because if
you don't then maybe only one of y'all
chutes opens you know what I'm saying
that way you know that way you know if
you're operating in the same vein as
Elle Lord you know as their Lord up so
that's not a bad idea at all go get out
there and know and take your girl
skydiving before you pop that ring out
because you don't know maybe her thang
doesn't open and God didn't want y'all
to be together and bam you can return
that jewelry piece you know you spend
half the jewelry amount on you know
maybe getting your girl a bad oak box
Center on the heaven and you back out in
the world I'm just joking man
man I'm getting dark tit I got to get
some rest let's take another call hey Bo
this is Parker
purchase
about pairs before and how you like
pairs and how it's on to rated fruit oh
I love pears dude
payers bro make you feel like a vampire
bite into a pear feel that [ __ ] run down
me a face dude now what are you not a
vampire think again more onward Parker
but what do you think about cantaloupe
brah what do I think about cantaloupe
I'll tell you sir cantaloupe is the most
a [ __ ] thing I've ever seen it's
underdeveloped whatever it is it's sick
it tastes like a premature baby
watermelon and then here's the worst
part is cantaloupe have this dirty dirty
little cousin this green cousin a la
Verde sucio and he is like it's unripe
and fruit it's basically a chunk of
unripened us and they pin they peddle
that [ __ ] off on you honeydew melon they
call it honeydew melon bro what is that
what is honeydew melon French Dodge dude
so the next thing you know they're
peddling this [ __ ] at you you go to
a lot of these cheap diners out here in
LA in LA they got a lot of these cheap
ass [ __ ] diners brah they you know
they say it's quality meats and [ __ ]
they got a C rating on the door they're
[ __ ] schlepping you over some you know
you know just melon you know little
melon balls and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know third you know you know truck you
know fake butter and all kind of [ __ ]
and just you know dip see you know dirty
magic headers and all of that and that's
where they give you the honeydew melon
and that stuff is a [ __ ] it doesn't
it taste like first of all you shouldn't
be eating it I think you've ever had it
but you taste like you're dang like your
tongue is gonna hit up on some kind of
list for even tasting it this [ __ ]
tastes really really young
and it's not even it's in its cheapy the
whole [ __ ] thing - probably cost 20
cents and the out here piddling these
big-ass chunks of it on to you and
selling you that [ __ ] at a premium get
the [ __ ] out of here with that take me
to a real diner where they serving
pineapple these are the things should be
allowed on a fruit dish pineapple
blueberries strawberries raspberries
raisins bro grapes and that's it not
this other just sheepy [ __ ] they
serving out here not that [ __ ] let's
hear more I don't hear a lot of people
talking about cantaloupe
I just don't think that's right it's one
of the your thoughts on that delicious
melon I later delicious melon dude bro
you know weeds cantaloupes man women in
the late 80s that's who and they haven't
caught its cheese with them and who's
even ever really heard of cottage cheese
where does it come from never seen that
never seen whatever animal it comes out
of but that's how I feel about it let's
take another call onward I feel buddy
from Texas oh it's a rainy Monday
morning and I listen to the podcast and
I saw you coming to ask well apparently
I missed the ticket sales crime so I
pulled up the stub club to see if I can
find some tickets some [ __ ] are
charging $85 to go see I'm not saying
you ain't worth it but want to get your
opinion what I'll tell you right now I'm
not worth it
I'm joking is look I don't here's the
thing the market the market dictates the
price people will pay so I'll say this
to you though because now if somebody I
don't feel like that that's the
brightest move especially the tickets
are not very expensive you know I never
try to charge too much for a ticket
because I believe that everybody should
be able to come and see the show now
there will be times where the tickets
may be little more there may be times
where the tickets will be little less
but I believe that everyone should have
the opportunity to come and see the show
so yeah well I what I buy those no also
I'm gonna be back here sometime in the
spring so I'll told you that right now I
don't know the date yet but I know that
that is a fact so won't you just wait on
daddy buddy and I'll come through over
there just take care of yourself don't
eat any [ __ ] orange melon or green
melon bra that [ __ ] do you think I'm
some [ __ ] son charge damn much money
when we hard-working people to try to
make it and uh Samantha wanna of the
price just to go see a show all right
well now have somebody bought 20 tickets
and they're doing all that and jacking
them up then you know may they get hit
by lightning brah or may somebody pull a
sword on them when they had a bus stop
and they drink in a [ __ ] milk or
something or you know one of those
gogurts one of them go-gurt hitters
because I'll be damned for us hard when
you got a big milk up to your face and
somebody hit you with a [ __ ] sore boy
come on [ __ ] get right get right let's
hear another call thank you for calling
dude and uh and if I don't see you this
time I'll see you next time hey this is
Evan from Texas as I keep hearing you
bring up the Bridges of Madison County
yeah cuz it's a great movie Evan thank
you for calling Moore and so I decided
to watch it and I cried but it was cause
I was bored to tears and I was wondering
is it a joke would you bring that up or
am I really just that dead inside okay I
want to hear your thoughts on that well
I mean I don't know if you're dead
inside but you probably are because it's
a great movie well Jimmy look do you
know anything about love Evan huh
won't you put your fingers up by your
dang neck and see if you even have a
pulse your little your little damn
garden snake
because The Bridges of Madison County
have client Eastwood in it one of the 30
[ __ ] greatest men ever he's basically
Neil Armstrong but he never left Earth
it has um it's not Gloria Estefan who is
that lady
um not Selena who is it
and [ __ ] I don't know it has a famous
actress in it who Oh Marilyn Street and
I get yeah I do get tired of hearing
some of her poetic you know I don't that
political rhetoric sometimes but she's a
great actress and they're in love man
it's got Iowa in it and it's got bridges
bruh then it's got sideboob dog what do
you need man you might want to take
yourself to the damn ICU and have them
hooked that [ __ ] machine up to you
the beep beep beep and see if you got
any upsy daisy's in you or if you just
saw flat Liese dude cuz I swear to god
bro your heartbeats sound like a damn
Oklahoma Prairie right now mean nothing
no gradient get out there and find
yourself a soul son here's here's how I
would do it I would start watching the
movie Old Yeller okay
then watch 101 Dalmatians that's cartoon
then do the movie up it's about a senior
citizen that gets his house taken away
after is about a bunch of balloons then
Thomas thought if you haven't seen that
it's like about early early cruise lines
then
[Music]
watch probably league of their own and
your [ __ ] heart will be open let's
hear more all word more call hey it's
Dan from Pittsburgh and gang gang dude I
got pink out there in the Monongahela
once and I got a I got a Earl a [ __ ]
one time over there behind a giant eagle
the giant eagle grocery over there now
to buckos you're a double yoi thanks
back down the fruit loop
oh car downstairs blind when paint blow
in the same trap and it's a man don't
wanna come down man
let's hear more I just want to let
everyone know to go out and the coatings
are really important especially here in
Pennsylvania we need everyone to vote to
legalize marijuana recreationally I
particularly need people to go out both
because I had that rights stripped away
from me
whenever I got caught selling marijuana
and they gave me a felony so now that
I'm felony charge I can't throw and this
is coming up and if it passes I can work
on getting my [ __ ] expunged you get a
clean record so please everyone out
there in Pennsylvania please vote thanks
dear I love what you do Jane gang gang
gang Braun I hope you get off free you
know i'm frank saying free weed baby
that's that dude right there and they
should let you go man cuz you just a
little guy out there with that pop with
that dope you just a plant you just want
a mother nature's haberdashers you're
just trying to fit people with that
giant and you shouldn't be bad bro you
know you shouldn't be you know just held
liable for that forever so
so yeah man I hope that you get taken
care of brah I hope you get taken care
of and you get treated well on you and
the weed gets passed and you know what
man I think it would be nice if from now
on we just voted on things that we
wanted and things that we did it you
know quit voting to spend all this money
for all these you know these Muppets out
there to run around even though dude
watching some politics is fun to watch
all these people get mad at each other
on online and everything I [ __ ] is
hilarious brah watching a bunch of
disconnected people get mad at each
other about everything I [ __ ] love it
dude I just don't see how at a certain
point your ego has to infect like I
don't know politician is a witness and
that whole thing is just I don't know I
just just want to wake up in fortnight
alright we got one last call for this
week man thank you guys for bearing with
me ja I just feel like I'm not even
making any sense I'm just so tired here
we go hey deal it's John come home from
Long Island New York
big Johnny from the Li more new digs
episode and you're talking about I think
about the future
ah I do that a lot too you know sprinkle
a little dark dark arts and a cigar and
light it up you start thinking about the
future and I was just wondering if you
ever considered I think about this
sometimes how impactful small decisions
that we make in the present could be in
the future that could be in a range of
things I mean there's a million examples
you know solving a problem today a
product that you create to change the
world however many years in the future
and that just blows my mind you know
like some dude invented plastic you know
at the time it was the most convenient
thing in the heppen world you know they
were like oh we could store [ __ ] man
that's just one weird example but it's
crazy how the small decisions that
people make in the small inventions that
get created in the present day watch
such a massive impact later on that
weird might not even be around for we
might not even be aware of what a good
beer is going to be it's just
mind blown bro dang dang hear your
thoughts baby Gang Gang John in the Li
that Long Island may be strong Island
dude thanks for calling man I you know I
always you know part of me always
wanting y'all like that movie Newsies
and I always wanted to be a New York boy
you know I always wish I had that kind
of hard and that pump and that you know
that bravado you know and always wanted
to be a part of something when I was
young and I always you know I saw it
that movie Newsies is another movie you
want to fall in love with yourself get
out there
imagine you a [ __ ] paperboy and you
got a sing too on all you know in the
afternoon shift [ __ ] unreal [ __ ]
those kids went to went through you got
to dress up like you know like a 70 year
old and sing and [ __ ] deliver papers
bruh we would fall apart today we don't
know what those men did watch Newsies
man but to get back to your to your
secure question yeah dude I think look I
think we don't know the effects of cell
phones on people there's no way they
tested a cell phone on somebody for 40
years to find out what you know what
what effects it was gonna have dude
anyway and some of the effects are so
obvious to us and that you know of cell
phone it's like now our cell phone but
has become us you know try putting your
phone out I'm walking away from it you
feel like you don't have any memory you
don't have any your memories you don't
have any ideas you don't have any you
have no friends it's crazy it's crazy
but yeah do we know do we know like the
long-term effects of things I mean in
and even could go back to a long time
ago if you think like you know maybe
there's a group that it first come to
America and they're settling or they're
you know taking over the land or
something they decided to make a road
and they make it one way instead of the
other way just for no real reason and
who knows
that changed the course of history you
know maybe then somebody grew up along
side of the road and the road was uh you
know right next to a you know where they
had a bear lived and I've been a baby
got attacked by a bear or kidnapped by
bears you know and then next thing you
know the baby's out there getting raised
by bears and then next thing you know
they got that jungle book movie but if
they picked the road the other way than
nothing you know the baby just grows up
by a road so it's just but yeah man it's
like what could happen what could happen
if you start something small right now
what could happen if you make a choice
to do something a little better for
yourself tomorrow what could happen what
could happen if I made a choice to
really you know commit to trying and
being in love you know or if I made a
choice to really I don't know but yeah
what could happen
gonna happen if you made a choice
instead of being angry at somebody
you're angry at to forgive them what
could happen
you
you know what could happen if you
decided to take the news off your phone
that's what I find you know I I had the
news off my phone forever and then at
some point I put it back on and then I
just decided to take it off and
immediately things have been better
what could happen if I started really
believing that the good things in the
world could be mine what could happen
and I know you meant that on some
different levels but just kind of
piecing those things together man that
if we make choices and we move forward
what could happen because this is it
this is life this is it
there's no you're not going to kind of
get through with you know this and then
it's going to be there done now there
could be something else there could be
reincarnation
where you wake up in different nations
your rien card in different nations but
for now this is it so what's your seeds
gonna look like but you're gonna plant
what you're gonna create what are you
gonna leave around you know I thought
about that I was thinking about man I
want to do some comedy and just do like
a rural tour you know maybe every year
every other year for a week or two
throughout the Midwest or in just in
rural areas people that don't get it you
know because when I lay it my by my
graveside you know I want to be able to
I want to be able to think about
something good that I did something that
wasn't to make money or something that
was until I could Vance a career or
something that wasn't just something to
make people feel good not just me feel
good you know because I imagine there's
people out there in this country ahead
they probably need maybe they saw a
comedian in their town when they were
you know 50 years ago or haven't seen
one sense you know but yet there was
just a little thought a seed a thought
seed that passed through my head but
it's interesting brother well you know
what do we what seats can we plant now
when you've been putting it off the
offered an apology
you could call someone that [ __ ]
wronged you and take part in it
I know that you wronged me you know I
know that your ancestors did this to me
but you know what I'm not gonna I'm
moving forward I'm not gonna let that
[ __ ] rip around in my head all day you
know I'm not going to teach that
my children
I'm not saying that look I'm just saying
that there you know what seed could you
plant look at you know you could plant a
seed in your own family and you know
your son said hey years ago I taught you
something and I shouldn't have taught
you that plant a seed of something new
tomorrow you could get up a little early
and go for a walk
grab your wife's hand before you go to
bed put her sneakers by the bed and just
say you know for 10 minutes before you
know the baby wakes up and you and me
let's go for a walk let's let the lower
watch the baby for a few minutes and you
and me go walk around the block you know
what
we do what seed can we plant that's a
good question
what effect can we have on our future
selves I bet we can I bet we can man we
can enjoy it
it's Halloween time the chakras are open
you can hear the graveyard is opening up
the portals are ajar and deceased are
returning and whether you're alive or
[Music]
pseudo alive you got an opportunity to
celebrate living
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate man
[Music]
you'll die
celebrate
[Applause]
[Music]
let's
while we all die have a great one and be
good to yourself
be good to yourself guys it's a special
time of year and you can make it special
be good to yourself man you probably
deserve it I love you see you next week